welcome thank you I'm Tia Julian Julian
okay nice to meet you how many kids do
you have I have one okay my name's una
she's two oh no I love that okay what
happened if you don't mind me asking
it's a little complicated yeah I'm
honestly not sure how so you get like
whatever you feel comfortable this is a
safe space
um
dog
why'd you reject me it is like maybe the
dog yeah
you can put it in a cage but you can't
put kids exactly that's the advantage to
having a dog if she acts bad you know
you just puts an occasion she cries for
a couple minutes
don't ever have kids don't have kids
don't have kids that's it that is some
of the darkest [__] I had and I don't
know if this [__] is joking
don't have kids I don't think he's
joking not with that haircut in that
[__] yeah you can just put her in a
cage and she's crying you can ignore her
you know you throw her a bone but she
doesn't need much to make her happy
you know what he looked like the creepy
version of Serge tank in oh yeah that
doesn't really look like me I thought it
was the same [__] for something
software version 7.0 looking at like
rich rich okay Rich I'm Tia Tia nice to
meet you nice to meet you
how many kids one okay so I feel like
that adds for me at least 10 years to my
life this is a single oh okay this is a
single parents Edition I was like why
they keep asking about [__]
kids single parents try the bun for the
first time okay cool cool and his kid
was a dog
you're not one of us yeah you're not get
the [__] out oh yeah 30 in dog years the
30 of dog years he's two and a half how
about your kid I have two boys two men
and about to be seven so seven what are
you looking for I want something serious
I'm over the whole messing around thing
something about a man think I want
something serious and he's wearing a
beanie that I just can't take seriously
yeah
like well you haven't even accepted your
baldness How You Gonna accept someone
else's child are you not even ready for
this I understand how you gonna be ready
for a whole bit oh baby yeah baby how
old are you I'm 25. okay I am 35
but guys if you're balding [__] not easy
but wearing a beanie ain't it it's not
because women already look at you
suspiciously because like why is this
guy always wearing a beanie what is he
really hiding and more you're not okay
with what you got going on you smell
like
a head
what yeah not head to head but head just
actual head okay you know when people
wear the the cap and they just where
they cap and that's the only thing they
wear and they sweating that [__] they
take that [__] up and it smells like
head okay all right they're not but you
know what I mean I'm tired
[Laughter]
I'm tired as well that's also my name
the recently started to do
did okay so you think you're funny
every girl says that you think you're
funny
tell me a joke is what I'm expecting
every girl says I know I'm funny
with the whole hey jester
let's see
I was like what I say I can dance and
people like Bust the Move I'm like
people look like a goddamn monkey
what are you doing I work in a bank open
an account I can't like it's not the
proper time exactly [__] yeah a goatee
jokes I have this one about like how uh
I've only been single okay if you gotta
explain a joke oftentimes it's always
going to come out funky as hell when you
explain the joke it's exactly like
dissecting a frog you understand the
joke but the frog dies yes two years
since me and my uh the mother of my
child to believe her while she was going
through the first apartment or something
no no no no we separated after he was
born she didn't want to be around me so
I mean it's a high school sweetheart
thing you just don't Mash after a while
I do receptor hey I got respect for her
too you better yeah of course you gotta
respect the baby mama I mean it's just
like you're a high school sweetheart
you've been together for six years covet
hit we were forced to spend time with
each other and we were like hey I
actually don't like you all right
but not because you're a bad version
right okay okay that's fine do you
struggle with honesty and transparency
not at all not at all why you gotta call
her baby mama though honestly this brown
is tripping she said I don't like you
she said I don't like you but she's not
said why she's like you struggle with
unseen transparency and I said why do
you call her baby mama boo boo if you
got issues with your baby daddy that's
between you and him don't be [__]
projecting that on anybody else who's in
a relationship yeah but she's projecting
whatever [__] yeah yeah she said this
man is the same when someone no no when
someone doesn't switch like that yes
it's yes something that you said but
it's more about how they interpreted and
their experience of what you said but
yeah that's a switch up I don't even
think it's that weird I don't think he
said you wanna think of this she wasn't
attracted to him so she was working back
from her conclusion she already wasn't
into him sure now she's just finding
reasons sure because if maze was mad
attractive she wouldn't be acting like
this
should be like why you call it a baby
mama yeah yeah
honestly on my phone she is mother of my
son okay okay but where's the joke you
told me the right okay oh hell no
the man was in the setup you interrupted
him said some routine about you don't
like him and you still want him to
render you a service
disrespectful ass [__] don't be talking
about a black woman like that hey I'll
say that to any woman who being a [__]
and I very guarantee you there's black
women watching right out of black now
she's being a [__] I guarantee you yeah
yeah it's not because the black woman
that you can't say if she doing is she
doing it I just don't do it unfair you
know yeah she earned that one you know
exactly what I said and why I said it
yeah you know
you know what yeah
I've been single for two years I mean I
said oh I'm digging the tax appreciate
it see you have one on your head yes
it's a crown because my mama raised the
king that's a stereotype
this is a whole episode about single
parents and you look at some of them
you're like I could see why you're
single parent
does she say the same she would she
actually passed away a few years ago my
condolences yeah yeah you got kids right
yes I have one how old is he yes he's
four and a half what about you I
actually am raising my little sister
balancing like the father-daughter
relationship with the brother sister
relationship we're in it together you
know what I'm saying I love her to death
that's my best friend oh I love to hear
that tell each other why someone
shouldn't date you you go first
um okay for one I think everything's a
sign I also love astrology
you love signs you got all these signals
from the world but you couldn't afford
being a single parent okay so astrology
not working out for your ass what
happened Venus and retrograde couldn't
tell you about to be goofing around by
yourself because 95 of people I dislike
like astrology for some reason and then
the other five percent are Ethan client
so we're doing pretty good percentages
what's your sign I'm a Libra everything
bro that's crazy
my last relationship was with the Libra
and so what's your sign I'm a cancer so
okay baby
Nadia what's your name Nadia Keyshawn
Keyshawn nice to meet you yes nice to
meet you too yeah yeah you're attractive
yeah likewise
I think you're hella cool we obviously
have hella in common but I always feel
like to want to go on a date with
someone I need to be like walk in a room
like I'm with that [__] right there
why you ain't got no alibi you ugly man
that's what he calls I'm with that [__]
over like she said what did you say who
wants to be that what did you not call
me yeah
[Laughter]
what did you call the [__] that don't
exist right now and that is not me but
it could have been me if I was that
[__]
Britain I have a seven-year-old my
daughter she's great what's your
relationship like with uh her dad we
actually have a really good relationship
ask Brittany why her and her baby daddy
are not together why are you and your
baby daddy not together
because we're cousins
[Music]
he cheated we just didn't work he
cheated a lot hey
why are you so happy I don't know
I just have you I guess right not about
her travel yeah she just she got the
face of someone who got cheated
why me wow wow with all the wells damn
gorgeous okay that's crazy
that's crazy what I think you so what
brings you all right we got something
hey this motherfucker's smooth as [__]
this mother hey my Pan African Brothers
we love to see it when a black queen and
a black king come together they create
an empire forget a kingdom this is a
chance for Zulu Nation to stand again my
brothers we don't want
no snow bunnies no Latin Mafia dealing
Taco selling Brothers calm the [__] down
with that we don't want no Gypsy
wandering people you can't say ships we
don't want no Kung Fu having Asia you
can't call them Kung Fu having that we
want that wakandan African pan-african
Egyptian origin love wakanda don't exist
what the [__] are you doing
and this is the Genesis because the
highest level of loyalty that you can
show as a black person to the black
struggle is to start a black family
that's why I don't want none of you race
Traders leaving comments below talking
about interracial listen mutts
months listen half breeds Half Breed
listen
Miss Mash crisscross don't know where to
[__] go when you cross the street
weird are you talking about [__]
you said yeah calm the [__] down
mishmash crisscross don't know where the
[__] you're going you crossing the
street are you high she's on one street
there's the black people I know what
you meant
[__] out of here
if you think about it though that's what
makes people are
no because there's white people on one
side there's black people on the other
side and they don't know where to go so
they're just walking around the street
till they get hit by a car by themselves
this is just my impression of Dr um I
enjoy doing it
if he's ever introduced someone to his
kid have you ever introduced anyone
you're dating to your children no you
can break my heart but you break his
heart that's a different story that's
one of my deal breakers like if you want
to meet my daughter too soon I feel like
that's a little odd so I normally don't
introduce people before like five months
right this is incredibly healthy and
respectable like these are all very like
good things that I think parents should
do being reluctant to invite the child
around the other person these are good I
don't know just sometimes good to
highlight when people are saying stuff
that I think it's not just logical but
very healthy
[Music]
go ahead
it's a pretty color though
congratulations you two are going on
another day together awesome
[Applause]
my dark purple African sister you have
found yourself your king we love to see
it we love to see it we love to see it
winter has passed spring has come it's
time for that African summer
good
it's okay you don't need to be ashamed
of the Snow Buddies come back
there's room and a chance for you to get
Redemption my brother
shut up
love who you want love do you want to do
I'm Lauren I'm Julian do you have kids I
do her name's una she's two oh nice I
have three kids
we're not the same we're not the same
we're not the same three kids just look
at us down I mostly DJ so is your
two-year-old like listening to music she
likes yeah she likes the the basement oh
my God my guy when she's gonna find out
it's a whole ass dog
Charlotte she gonna feel like she's been
LED on and that's where she's gonna
press that [__] yeah he went from
Cafeteria on Facebook to DJing my man's
trying to improve or trying to make
trying to make Anne's neat it's amazing
how quickly they develop like a taste
and like a certain kind of music they
like yeah
[Music]
of course you know why she's looking at
that she says
I got three kids
my standards are low
but they ain't that long
hey ladies you deserve better definitely
better than that I'm Lauren Lauren good
to meet you so you got any kids I have
one daughter she'll be nine next month
nice I have one that'll be nine in April
oh that's my youngest and I have a 13
and then my oldest is non-binary and
they are going to be 17 in May which is
like such a trip for our daughters we
went camping this last summer we're at
Walmart getting supplies she's this
pride hat she's like I want this hat I'm
like what is this and she like when she
explains like oh people can be who they
want to be love who they want to love
it's just what it is and I was like okay
you can have the hat like you understand
it and then the kids are so much more
open and accepting to that kind of thing
yeah I grew up in a religious family so
it was very like
Sean upon you're going to the town
you're gonna burn if you think this way
and all that stuff have your parents
changed over time or like and become
more accepting this is the first episode
of the bun we're about to get two
couples because like the chemistry is
off the charts with these two yeah yeah
well that's that's lucky I have a good
relationship with my dad now but
unfortunately my mom isn't in my life
anymore so what are you two looking for
I'm looking for somebody to like wants
to hang out I work and I'm constantly
doing a lot so I'm not looking to be
like like constantly going yeah I say
I'm very similar looking for someone
kind of fun times to do things with the
kids we have to go mushroom hunting
we like to go okay we do a lot of
swimming she just got into like gaming I
got her own PlayStation and her own
headset her own gamer tag are you too
interested in going on another day
[Music]
congratulations you two have learned
yourself huh that is crazy two in one
episode
hey I just want to say for all this
stick that single parents get it's cool
to see them be the most reasonable ones
when it comes to dating maybe life
humbles them kids and you start to
realize what really matters in life but
it's interesting that we often talk
about single people you'll get like two
three episodes nobody matches the thing
that happened is that they're tired
go on be tired yeah they got other [__]
they got other [__] yeah there's other
[__] to do yeah you know I mean like
these scene being around the world yeah
yeah yeah they've been to the other
zones the lows yeah you know what I mean
so they're like okay yeah
that check all the important stuff yeah
let me get to the the real things you
know I mean I just want to say
shout out to single parents right now
because y'all taking a big old W yeah
because when it comes to the dating
landscape and everybody being crazy and
ridiculous you're seeing these two
episodes where people are meeting
they're taking the time to get to know
each other and they're open that's
awesome so good for that that was good
that was really good that was good so I
got to give it to the cut I got to give
it to the people who showed up so that's
it anything you want to say no